(audience clapping)
- All right everybody,
I always like to finish up
with something uplifting.
Here's today's #What I'm Liking.
(lively upbeat music)
(audience clapping)
Back in our first season,
Kaley Cuoco introduced me
to her friend and manager,
Andrea Pett-Joseph.
Andrea's son, Brandon was
born with a super rare disease
that makes his skin as
fragile as butterfly wings.
He constantly suffers wounds and blisters.
Andrea does everything she can
to give Brandon a normal
and comfortable life,
but she's also on a
mission to find a cure,
so no other child has to go through this.
We have Andrea on the line right now.
So say hi to Andrea everybody.
(audience applauds)
Hi, Andrea.
- Hello.
- Hello, it's good to see you again.
So it's been three years now.
How's Brandon doing?
- It has been three years, which is crazy.
You know, as you know, he's got EB,
and that has its set of challenges.
So there's been health
issues on a daily basis.
And he's also had some great milestones
since we last saw you.
He graduated from high school.
- [Kelly] Oh, wow.
(audience applauds)
- He started college at LMU.
- That's so awesome.
Yeah, there he is. (laughs)
But he remains positive
and hopeful, as do we.
And we're just really, really proud of him
and all his accomplishments.
- Oh, me too, that's incredible,
all the things that he's accomplished.
So remind everybody though,
about your foundation,
the EB Medical Research Foundation.
So like, how can they help?
- Well, yeah, so we started
the foundation in L.A.
when Brandon was born, and
our goal is to raise money
and to raise awareness for EB.
We fund numerous researchers
and universities who have projects.
So that's sort of our main goal.
Our biggest fundraiser is coming up,
which we're really excited
about, to be back in person.
It's our Rock4EB! that we do.
It's our sixth year of doing it.
And we've had Ed Sheeran
perform, Eddie Vedder,
Adam Sandler, Chris Cornell, Sting,
and this year we've got Brandi Carlile,
and Judd Apatow and Kevin Nealon,
so we're really excited
to be back in person.
And we're selling tickets,
and it's just a great, magical night,
and everyone comes out for
the cause and the music
and the great food,
and it's a really incredible night
for all of us to help raise
awareness and funds for EB.
So we're very excited about that.
(audience applauds)
- Man, congratulations on that.
To find out more about the EB
Medical Research Foundation
and how you can help
the search for a cure,
go to "The Kelly Clarkson
Show" Insta Story right now.
Thank you so much everybody,
and thank you, Andrea.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience cheers)
- [Andrea] Thank you.
- Absolutely, and that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the Go-To Pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show,"
want to honor truly unstoppable people
just like you, ma'am.
So, they're gonna be writing
the EB Medical Research Foundation a check
for a thousand dollars.
(audience cheers)
- Oh my god.
Wow, thank you so-
- Yeah.
- Oh, that's incredible.
Thank you, thank you all so much.
That's really, really appreciated.
(audience cheers)
- Absolutely, girl.
Okay, and thank you to all
of our guests this hour,
Rachel Brosnahan, Alex
Borstein, Tony Shalhoub,
Michael Zegen, Carey Hart,
and Thee Sacred Souls.
Y'all have a great day.
If it's not, we'll try and change it.